at first i didn't believe it i was like
man these people are obviously trying to
destroy dr cosby's rich legacy
even 34 allegations into it i was still
like
man
probably only raped 10 or 11 of those
people
i know i know but it's really tough you
know you guys are young so imagine if
you found out 40 years from now that
kevin hart raped 54 people
the only one that would believe that
would be cat williams i knew that
[__] was after something
stop worshiping celebrities so much just
don't listen pay attention
i remember right around september 11th
uh ja rule was on mtv that's what they
say so we got y'all rule on the phone
let's see what jaws thoughts are
on this tragedy who gives a [__] with
john rule thinks at a time like this
think this is ridiculous
i don't want to dance i'm scared to
death
i want some answers that john rule might
not have right now
i think when bad [__] happens to me i'll
be in the crib like oh my god this is
terrible
because nobody please
find y'all rule get hold of this
[__] so i can make sense of all
this
where is job
i have to meet your room
i don't even know why people listen to
me
i'll say anything [__] i've done
commercials for coke and pepsi i don't
give a [__] what comes out of my mouth i
just say what it takes whatever it takes
that's what i'm saying
if you want to know the truth
can't even taste the difference
surprise
all i know was pepsi pay me most
recently so
tastes better
that's pretty much how the game goes
i'm just being real man there's too much
gugging over celebrities people don't
know what's fake and what's real anymore
that's why bill cosby got in trouble
look what happened to bill cosby bill
cosby says some real [__] and the whole
world freaked out on
for what for having an opinion just
because he was selling pudding pots for
the last 40 years people forget that
he's a [__] from philly in the projects
and he might say some real [__] from
time to time
it's not that big of a deal i spoke at
my old high school and i told them kids
straight up if you guys are serious
about making it out of this ghetto you
got to focus
you got to stop blaming white people for
your problems
and you've you've got to learn how to
rap or play basketball or something look
at your trap you are trapped
either do that or sell crap that's your
only option that's the only way i've
ever seen it work you better get to
entertaining these white people
go on out there and be somebody
i just hope they listen
[Music]
[__] is ridiculous people worship
television they worship this [__] you
know like if you watch a movie right say
watching a movie and one character says
another character say hey uh what's your
number man what's the other character
always say five five five five five five
five
you know why we gotta do that because
stupid as people go to the movies and
then go home and try to call the
characters that they just saw hello is
indiana jones here no [__] he's
fake it's not his number
and to be honest this is the worst time
in history to be a black celebrity [__]
they locking all our stars up
it's hot right now for black celebrities
i knew it was bad when kobe got in
trouble i said this is a wrap for us
he's one of the most wholesome dudes we
had
lock them up and everything
kobe kept it together thank god he he
held his game together because if he was
cracking under pressure and getting like
six points a game
the whole l.a would have been like that
[__] is guilty
[Applause]
kobe was playing his ass off
he was playing like his freedom depended
on that [__]
you see this [__] game this
[__] trying to beat that case on the
court
like the judge doing the ball like play
for your freedom
[Applause]
caitlyn jenner whom i've met wonderful
person caitlyn jenner
was voted
woman of the year
her first year as a woman ain't that
something beat every [__] in detroit
she's better than all of you
never even had a period ain't that
something
[Applause]
oh i'd be mad as [__] if i was a woman
i'd be mad if i was me if i was in a bet
awards sitting there and then like in
the winter for [__] of the year
eminem
[Applause]
and that's why i don't trip off being a
celebrity i don't like it
i don't trust it just one minute they
all love you the next thing you know
you're in front of that courthouse
dancing on top of a car just trying to
figure out what the [__] happened to you
[Applause]
that's what i'm waiting for because the
timing of this michael jackson [__] is
what makes me doubt it
every time there's war is going out of
control or the economy gets bad or
something is wrong with the world at
large it's always these moments in
history that
michael jackson will coincidentally
jerk awful kid this is getting
ridiculous
like are you planning this [__] do you
have meetings
michael thank you for coming
as you know michael the war has not been
going as well as we expected there's
been a lot of hiccups and the public is
asking us
a lot of questions of course and well
michael there's no nice way to say this
and all i know how to do is be direct so
let me just be direct
we're gonna need you to jerk off another
child mike i'm sorry
i am sorry
but it would really help out
or maybe he didn't who knows
who knows that's the thing that's what i
wanted to say who knows who the [__]
knows mike god and this little boy know
that's that's about it
that's about it the only reason that i
can even talk about this [__] is because
everybody is
speculating they all think he did it and
i don't think he did it i'm alone in
this i don't think he did it i'm not
gonna say i don't think he did it that's
too strong
[Music]
let me just say i am reserving judgment
until all the facts come out
but so far from what i heard i mean the
kid said he was dying of cancer he was
in make-a-wish foundation he claims he
had two weeks to live and it was his
dying wish
to meet michael jackson
come on man give me a [__] break this
kid is 10 years old he don't remember
thriller the [__] you want to meet
michael jackson for honestly
i remember thrilling i just like kind of
want to meet this thing like
i wouldn't break an appointment to meet
him i put it that way i'd have to
already be free
that's ridiculous like if i'm down in
two weeks and go oh mama oh
get me in the room with chubby chuckle i
wouldn't want to meet that [__]
that
my leg is two weeks why not usher
somebody like this
so then the kid clings
he goes to michael's house this is where
it all gets crazy i don't like you know
he does everything you'd expect at
michael's house they uh climbed trees
and rode roller coasters and ferris
wheels the chef made cookies pies and
cakes they was petting the monkey and
the giraffes sing songs
kid [__]
and in the middle of all this childlike
activity
for some reason
mike pulled out some wine and some pills
[Applause]
and suck this kid's dick
folks it hurts me to save it
and the kid had the nerve to call that
abuse [__] that is a good host
god damn what else do you want
what else do you want
i'm lucky to get a glass of
a great drink in my friend's house
let alone a roller coaster ride my dick
sucked
mike must be confused like i brought you
in my house i fed you i sucked your dick
and this is how you repay me
[__]
this was your wish not man
i thought you were dying in two weeks
what happened to that [__]
i've been in court for a year and a half
to get strong every time i see you
when that
this is [__] up i shouldn't even say
the [__] wouldn't be some ironic [__] if
they found out through this case that
the cure for cancer was michael jackson
sucking your dick somehow
[Applause]
like if mike had powers like green mile
and all the kids like please mike's i
got this never again
really didn't appreciate it
can we at least study your saliva
please
it just doesn't stop though it just
doesn't stop and the only reason i can
talk about mike is because he's a freak
he's a freak
that's why people let you talk about it
because if i brought up catholic priests
[__] kids it'll get quiet as [__]
but
but when michael jackson does it it's
okay because he's a freak his face is
all cut up but just remember when you
look at that thing that he calls his
face
that he did that for you somehow
somehow he thought you might maybe it'll
help maybe people will like me more if i
turn myself into a white
ghoulish like creature i don't know what
the [__] it is
but he did it for you
and i appreciate the gesture michael
jackson if you're watching this i
appreciate that gesture and i want you
to know [__] everybody dave chappelle
understands because you want to know
something i'm getting some work done
surprise yes
nothing major you would never know if i
didn't tell you but it's some [__] i'm
insecure about that i want to work on
if you must know i'm getting botox done
on my bowls to get these wrinkles out
finally
have these [__] smooth as eggs